20 20 Democrats running into trouble on
the trail and in some cases with their
own voters now the case in point
just yesterday school choice advocates
crashed Elizabeth Warren's campaign
event in Atlanta while she spoke about
the contributions of african-american
women
[Applause]
no one is here so quiet you Oh an
interesting look for Warren and Ayana
Presley remember she's a squad member
shouting down black women who want
choice now I first saw those signs I'm
like this is about abortion no this is
about school choice they want to be able
to send their kids to top schools just
like everybody else well joining me now
is Charlie Kirk founder and president of
turning-point USA and Leo Tyrell civil
rights attorney Greg see you both
tonight now Leo did that look good for
senator Warren it looks great a
tremendous support and those protesters
let's be honest to your viewers they
were funded by the Walton family who
should be paid living wages and that
group has nothing in common with choice
they were paid protestor lores and I
challenge anyone to dispute that fact
though they were funded by the Walton
family and I Got News for You the Walton
family has nothing to do and should that
nothing to do with the education in
California by the way Laura I went to
public school they did pretty well I'm
on the Laura Ingram show
yeah the Cato Institute's report on this
charlie shows that most African
Americans want in support school choice
and the Waltons have done an enormous
amount to advance the cause of quality
education for all children including
minority children across the board but I
thought that was a telling moment yeah
Leo I'm stunned by that comment
you're invalidating legitimate concerns
of working black women in our era Center
in our inner cities that are sending
their kids to failing public schools and
want to have more choice charters race
Carly there's a reason why in New York
City there is a lottery literally a
lottery where they pick at total random
individuals and families to get a chance
to go to better schools in Florida for
example governor Ron de Santos won the
election by promising and running on
school choice and black womens supported
that by the way
then you can go go ahead charlie
he was later can she was later
confronted by one of these protesters
and she said you sent your kids to
private school she denied it which is a
lie she did send her kids to private
school so why can send her Elizabeth
Warren send her kids to better schools
when these black women can't you know
you know it's disingenuous for you to
play the race card I'll say this again
Charlie would you ignore that group of
protesters were funding for the
repetition leo okay two genuine first of
all the left has made a cottage industry
out of paying protesters I have no idea
they're paid not paid I didn't look like
it to me maybe they got signs from I
don't know but Planned Parenthood
canvasses all over Washington DC
okay pace people minimum wage to can't
hold out clipboard saying sign this for
abortion right so don't tell me about
paid pamphleteers or protesters because
the left has done this on the border on
abortion and pretty much every other
issue and I don't hear you complain
about why I'm saying this is or that
charter school number one goal is make a
school choice and you don't okay Lauren
was not alone yesterday though
immigration activists they heckled Joe
Biden over deportations during the Obama
years watch
you should go for Trump you should vote
for Trump but if you have four or five
duis you can stay in the country as long
as you want
all right the timing here is so
interesting Obama Charlie just warned
the Democrats against these divisive
purity tests and this is a test on
whether or not you're open borders
enough Charlie yeah it's stunning how
the Democrat Party just seems to be
going in the direction of wanting to
cater to foreign nationals Joe Biden
says something somewhat would consider
be extreme now in the Democrat Party say
I don't want to stop all deportations
and then he gets protesters however just
some political advice for Joe Biden
never recommend to anyone to go to vote
for your opponent that's never going to
work instead of trying to win them over
and just trying to completely dismiss it
doesn't make a lot of sense to me but
it's amazing how the Democrat Party now
is just basically saying we want open
borders and no limitations what so you
know what you can't get in here for a
second Joe Biden is Trump's worst
nightmare because according to Charlie
everyone the Democratic talking point
says the Democrats won't open border Joe
Biden does not Joe Biden is contrary to
the position of open borders and those
crazies who are there when it comes to
the June election they're gonna vote for
Joe Biden over Trump because Trump has a
problem with minorities I'm sorry
Charlie that that would ever sell yeah
that's that's why that's why everybody
has to run around calling Donald Trump a
racist Donald Trump's a zine if this is
all they have because otherwise they
have to talk about the economic record
otherwise they have to talk about what
he's done for criminal justice reform so
they don't want to talk about substance
but they want to brand people to shut
down all conversation I gotta say I
think people are tired of it leo I
really think and Charlie I think people
want to get to some solutions I think
they're fairly reasonable maybe people
shouldn't tweet so much Trump and
everybody else but I think in general
people just want the country to do well
well I just really think that I will put
this way off off point here I really do
I hope Trump her what you just said
about not tweet as much because I Got
News for you you can't talk
the economy because Trump injects
himself into every social issue and
that's it then why are the Democrats so
paranoid charlie that every week it
seems like another person's getting in
the race because they know that this is
flatlining in the battleground states
they should move in the needle and Pete
Moo de jedge is not gonna be President
of the United States okay god bless them
but South Bend Indiana a mayor is not
gonna be President the United States
maybe down the road but not this time
Charlie Joe that's right and Reese and a
recent poll shows that Donald Trump is
up against every major Democrat in
Wisconsin and doing quite well in states
like Florida North Carolina we gotta go
thank you so much I don't mean to cut
you off but we're gonna get cut off
otherwise